president biden and his party have sent
us back in time to the late 70s and
early 80s
when runaway inflation was hammering
families a violent crime wave was
crashing our city
cities and the soviet army was trying to
redraw the world
even before taking the oath of office
the president told us that he wanted to
quote make america respected around the
world again and to unite us here at home
he's failed on both fronts
and the president's approach to foreign
policy has consistently been too little
too late
it's time for america to once again
project confidence it's time to be
decisive it's time to lead
but we can't project strength abroad if
we're weak at home
and that's what i want to discuss with
you tonight
the president and democrats in congress
have spent the last year either ignoring
the issues facing americans or making
them worse
they were warned that spending trillions
would lead to soaring inflation
they were told that their anti-energy
policies would send gas prices to new
heights but they plowed ahead anyway
raising the price at the pump by 50
percent and pushing inflation to a
40-year high
four decades ago when our nation was
last reeling from inflation i was a
young working mom to starting out
my husband kevin worked days while i
watched our girls and then we would
literally switch
we would pass in the yard as he was
coming home and i was leaving to work
evenings at the local grocery store
from across that checkout counter i saw
the pain of inflation on my neighbors
faces
i saw what happens when prices rise
faster than wages
the biden administration believes
inflation is a quote high class problem
i can tell you it's an everybody problem
i saw moms and dads paychecks by them
less and less
i watched working people choose which
essentials to take home and which ones
to leave behind
and now president biden's decisions
have a whole new generation feeling that
same pain
when i took the oath of office five
years ago i promised iowans that i would
never lose sight of who i was working
for
that i wouldn't become detached from the
problems they were facing from the
problems that i had faced myself
but you don't have to check groceries to
see what high inflation does to people
you just need to step outside of the dc
bubble
talk to americans about what's on their
mind
ask them what are your concerns what
keeps you up at night and they'll tell
you
and i can tell you what's not on that
list
they won't tell you that spending
trillions more and bankrupting their
children is the answer to their problems
they won't tell you that we should be
paying people not to work
and they certainly won't tell you that
we should give billions in tax giveaways
to millionaires and billionaires in
democrat controlled states like
california new york and new jersey
but that's what the biden administration
has been pushing for over the last year
and that's all part of build back better
thankfully the president's agenda didn't
pass because even members of his own
party said enough is enough
well
the american people share that view
enough is enough
and it's not just with dc spending
americans are tired of a political class
trying to remake this country into a
place where an elite few tell everyone
else what they can and cannot say what
they can and cannot believe
they're tired of people pretending the
way to end racism
is by categorizing everybody by their
race
they're tired of politicians who tell
parents they should sit down
be silent and let government control
their kids education and future
frankly they are tired of the theater
where politicians do one thing when the
cameras are rolling and another when
they believe you can't see them
where governors and mayors enforce
mandates but don't follow them
where elected leaders tell their
citizens to stay home while they sneak
off to florida for sun and fun
where they demand that your child wear a
mask but they go maskless
so you've heard the excuses
they were just holding their breath
but it's the american people who are
waiting to exhale
waiting for the insanity to stop
we now live in a country where violent
crime is out of control
liberal prosecutors are letting
criminals off easy and many prominent
democrats still want to defund the
police
you know it seems like everything is
backwards the biden administration
requires vaccines for americans who want
to go to work or protect this country
but not for migrants who illegally cross
the border
the department of justice treats parents
like domestic terrorists but looters and
shoplifters roam free the american
people are left to feel like they're the
enemy
this is not the same country it was a
year ago the president tried to paint a
different picture tonight but his
actions over the last 12 months don't
match the rhetoric
it's not what he promised when he took
office
but it doesn't have to be that way
there is an alternative
across the nation republican governors
and legislators are showing americans
what conservative leadership looks like
what it means to respect the people we
serve to hear them out to stand up for
them and walk alongside them
we know that our problems require bold
action but we also know that bold action
doesn't have to mean government action
it's americans making their own
decisions for their own families and
future
republican governors faced the same
covid19 virus head-on
but we honored your freedoms and saw
right away that lockdowns and school
closures
they came with their own significant
cost
that mandates weren't the answer
and we actually listened to the science
especially with kids in mask and kids in
schools
what happened and is still happening to
our children over the last two years is
unconscionable
learning loss isolation anxiety
depression
in so many states our kids have been
left behind and so many will never catch
up
that's why iowa was the first state in
the nation to require that schools open
their doors
i was attacked by the left i was
attacked by the media
but it wasn't a hard choice it was the
right choice
and keeping schools open is only the
start of the pro-parent pro-family
revolution that republicans are leading
in iowa and states across this country
republicans believe that parents matter
it was true before the pandemic and it
has never been more important to say out
loud
parents matter
they have a right to know
and to have a say in what their kids are
being taught
families also have every right to live
in a safe and a secure community
and that begins with a safe and secure
country
but the biden administration has refused
to secure our border
they've refused to provide the resources
to stop human trafficking
to stop the staggering influx of deadly
drugs coming into our neighborhoods
they've refused to protect you
with texas and arizona leading the way i
along with republican governors from
several states have sent resources to
the border
and we've actually gone to the border
something that our president and vice
president have yet to do since taking
office
on the economy the contrast couldn't be
more stark
while democrats in dc are spending
trillions sending inflation soaring
republican leaders around the country
are balancing budgets and cutting taxes
because we know that money spent on main
street is better than money spent on
bureaucracy
today i signed legislation that
eliminates iowa's tax on retirement
income and sets our tax rate at 3.9
that's less than half of what it was
just four years ago
and it shouldn't come as a surprise that
out of the top 20 states with the lowest
unemployment rates
17 have republican governors
republicans may not have the white house
but we're doing what we can to fill the
leadership vacuum and on the issues that
are affecting americans
republicans are leading
we're standing up for parents and kids
we're standing up for life
we're keeping our communities safe and
thanking those in uniform
we're fighting to restore america's
energy and dependence and that includes
biofuels we're getting people back to
work not paying them to stay home
most of all
we're respecting your freedom
behind me stands iowa's capital where we
display our state motto
our liberties we prize and our rights we
will maintain
and those aren't just empty words it's a
belief that the greatness of this state
and this country
lies in our people not government
you shouldn't have to wake up every
morning and worry about the next thing
the government is going to do to you
your business or your children
if we as elected leaders are doing our
job then the government is working well
but operating in the background
it's supporting the ingenuity and spirit
of our people not drowning them out it's
keeping them safe not restricting their
freedom
that's what i believe
that's what republicans believe
and that's what republicans are doing
i am so blessed to be the governor of
iowa where people are humble
hard-working and patriotic we take care
of each other and yes we are as they say
iowa nice
but you don't have to be from iowa to
see that those are the values of america
at its best
all of america
over the last few years i've put my
faith in iowans and they haven't let me
down
i encourage this president to do the
same
to put his faith in you the american
people who have never wavered in your
belief in this country regardless of who
leads it
because you know
you've shown that the soul of america
isn't about who lives in the white house
it's men and women like you in every
corner of this nation
who are willing to step up and take
responsibility
for your communities for your neighbors
and ultimately for yourselves
by that most important measure at least
the state of our union is indeed strong
thank you
god bless you and god bless the united
states of america
in paid and fit family medical leave for
our workers
from the baristas at home
in my home
community in great lakes coffee to the
teachers in minnesota to the amazon
workers in alabama
workers are speaking up for a voice in
dignity on the job
i saw what a union
meant for my family growing up
as my father was a
member of the united auto workers
this access to dental care
so this is our time this is our time to
take on corporate polluters
who get rich poisoning us and we fight
for environmental
justice
with a green new deal we rebuild our
country by creating millions
millions of union jobs in the clean
energy industry of the future
and mad jobs and innovation for the next
century
and we'd ensure
clean air and water because i know we
can't build back better
if our children can't live healthy lives
a working families majority would take
on skyrocket
marketing housing costs which have left
a half a million americans
homeless and in long overdue rental down
payment and home repair assistance
we would provide a real path to
citizenship for our people
who want nothing more than to contribute
to our nation
we would transform our broken
immigration system into one
where immigrants are welcomed not
vilified
over the work together towards an
immediate cease-fire and a diplomatic
resolution to help save lives
we must pursue targeted sanctions
that put pressure on russia's
billionaires not the everyday russians
who have no choice in this conflict and
are courageously protesting the war as
we speak
we need a humanitarian response to this
crisis we must welcome ukrainian
refugees from all walks of life to the
united states
and i know we can't seek peace by
continuing to spend three quarters of a
trillion dollars every year on weapons
of war making defense contractors and
companies
wealthier
we must we must put human rights and
dignity first and prioritize cooperation
and diplomacy to address the challenges
that no one nation can confront alone
like pandemics and climate change
nothing is more important than keeping
the people we love free from harm
we all deserve to be safe in our
neighborhoods
the path to community safety is
investing in what people will need to
thrive like access to jobs quality
education and real opportunities
care
care not more criminalization is how we
ensure lasting safety for all
and we should end the war on drugs
fund legal defense and enact
criminal justice reforms like ending
qualified immunity
that would should transform our
discriminatory legal system
and we should add a justice for working
people to the supreme
in court by confirming cantanji brown
jackson without delay
over the last two years the richest
people that skyrocket
corporations have the nerve to blame
inflation while increasing
prices on essential goods and services
this is
more than simply corporate greed
it's
extortion we need to tax billionaires
and megacorporations
that dodge their fair share
and we
those policies i named they are popular
but we have a
a system that makes it too easy for
elected officials to answer to donors
instead of their constituents
just
fortunate representation in the senate
distorts the democratic will of
the people
the filibuster in the senate like the
house did more than a century ago
republicans are trying to destroy
destroy our political power of working
class families and they're willing to
tear down our democracy to do it
they
say the violent insurrection on general
eliminating our elections is just free
speech
republicans act like the real danger to
our
democracy is having enough voting booths
in black neighborhoods
mail-in ballots
their district lines
if we really wanted then we need voting
rights protection
you